these angels taking swings against
26 year old right-hander michael king
yeah michael king has got a really good
sinker he's going to rely on that slider
and change up but the command if he can
command the baseball
then he's got a chance in going a little
deeper than he has
don't expect him to go much more in five
he hasn't done that
for the yankees to turn it over to their
bullpen and he's trying to do something
that uh
i'm gonna go on a limb right now and say
that uh shohei ohtani
will get a hit in yankee stadium
so one gone base is empty for ohtani
and ohtani gets one in his first dead
bet
the bronx got it dude is amazing
told you to get a hit oh man
well i mentioned the back foot this one
was not in the back foot area this was
up and it stayed on the inner half of
the plate and he is locked
in right now there's nothing that seems
to bother this young man
and he knows it toronto is off today and
that means shohei otani has tied
vladimir guerrero jr with his
26th homer of the season
he is not of this world i'm telling you
he's from outer space
has to get going but see how that
breaking ball stayed in the middle
and he just would obliterate numbers
here at yankee stadium because he can go
anywhere he can go center left right
and that ball got out in a hurry here's
jared walsh now
walsh centers up a ball and sends it out
to deep left center field that's off the
base of the fence
rendon's being waved around
throw to the plate not nearly in time
two-nothing angels on an rbi doubled by
jared walsh
and michael king's first inning troubles
continue
dylan bundy has a two-run lead to work
with before he throws his first pitch
tonight on the road looking for win
number two will set results for bundy
haven't been good you see the era has
been high
and the record of course speaks for part
of that
and the angels could desperately use in
starting pitching
to give them a chance especially when
they score runs
here's gary sanchez now 13 homers 29
rbis
second and third with nobody out
and sanchez bounces it to rendon who
will concede the run for the out
le mayhew scores it's a 2-1 ball game
credit gary sanchez with an rbi is 30th
tonight
i'm a little surprised yeah i want to
say rendon had a chance at a play at the
plate
with le mayhew breaking on contact he
sure did and it would have been awfully
tempting here in this stadium
to not give up the run and see if you
can keep the game
you know well in check but that that's
good base running if it's on contact but
he was out
you know and he just decided not to make
that throw
giorgillo hanging around on one and two
here banning with one out and the base
is empty
looks like urchella just got one and
this game is
tied to a piece
[Applause]
number 10 for giovanni or shella
the 15th home run allowed by dylan bundy
in his 14 starts shohei otani leads
things off against michael king
top half of ending number five a 2-2
ballgame ohtani rendon
and walsh for the angels got him
they stayed with the hard stuff
anthony rendon on the first pitch that's
well struck out to right center judge
and gardner are there it's off the wall
judge brings it in anthony brendon to
second on a one out double
one hop to le mayhew that one eats him
up they get the out at second the
relay's not in time a run scores the
angels go back out on top
so suarez has worked through the lineup
once without allowing a hit and now it's
dj le mayhew with the bases empty and
two gone
lemay hughes slugs a bouncing ball up
the middle off balance throw
gets him what a play by iglesias
call that havana magic in anaheim
switch hitter luisa and hifo now he has
singled tonight
2-1 to rennhifo out to right field judge
coming on to make the catch
throw into first and an easy double up
of iglesias
wow we're gonna have to see here what
happened that was not a
ball that you thought off the bat was
gonna go
for a hit he just he just doesn't pick
it up for some reason
i mean judge is running in towards him
unfortunately that's kind of a whiff
so now two out bases empty for juan
lagar is
[Applause]
out to deep right field that one's got a
chance and it goes just the second of
the year for laguaris
this is about as center cut as they come
and
everything in the plate appearance was
in that same
part of the plate that back door sliders
and cutters out there and that one hung
and legarr has hit it a long way
two gone for giancarlo stanton with the
bases empty
the next 3-2 to stanton oh that's hit a
bunch
and gone wow first mistake he's made all
night well the mistake was the pitch
selection
i wasn't crazy about it i mean you'll go
back and look at that as your
as he's been perfect all night no reason
to throw that pitch and try to surprise
stanton who is a
monster on pitches up in the zone here's
jose iglesias now
out to right field and well hit
frazier's got to play it off the base of
the wall
schedler coming around he stumbles le
mayhew's throw is
way off line when this ball's hit
it's smoked to right field don't know if
judge would have made a difference if he
was out there
but watch on the carom okay the ball
gets off the wall the carom
and then he's looking there instead of
just going for the ball and throwing it
to where they're calling it for and then
that throw just sails he was out at home
reichel iglesias will try to close down
an angel
win on the road here easier said than
done
in a ballpark that has not been kind on
the angel since it opened in 2009 big
labor torres batting in a two-run
game with nobody on and two gone here in
the ninth
got him with a fastball iglesias with a
perfect
night striking out the side his 14th
save of the year
and the angels despite a short start by
dylan bundy
one that doesn't get them out of the
second inning
steal the first in a four-game series
5-3
the final score tonight